uh our next speaker is matt fielder
matt's the co-founder of vinyl me please
a kick-ass record of the month club with
over 2000 subscribers
matt uh is flying in from boulder
colorado to be here which is awesome and
he's going to describe some of the
things that he's learned while growing
by me please and just a reminder for the
lightning talks there will be no q a but
they're all going to be hanging out
throughout the day so you can ask all
your questions then
hi guys my name like sam said is matt
fiedler i'm one of the co-founders of
vinyl please
so finally please is a record of the
month club designed to create an
experience around music every month we
feature one record that we believe to be
essential
and package it up with a custom cocktail
pairing and a limited edition art print
and send it out to subscribers worldwide
so every month we ship out our records
worldwide to more than 2000 subscribers
in addition to the record subscribers
get access to something called the
standard which is a weekly digest
covering the latest in music and
lifestyle
so when we first started this idea back
at the end of 2012 we had like many of
you a kernel of an idea we wanted to get
feedback from it we wanted to understand
what people thought about it what
if they were interested in a service
like this and more or less if they'd be
willing to pay for it
so we solicit a lot of our friends
families co-workers and whatnot trying
to get their understanding and what we
got back was a lot of negative feedback
people said that they weren't willing to
pay for something like this that they
were skeptical of getting a record that
they may or may not like or that they
potentially already had labels said that
it just won't work that people have
tried to do it before and failed pretty
miserably we even talked to an executive
at
the country's largest vinyl pressing
plant and he basically said that was a
dumb idea but thanks for trying
so as you can imagine we were pretty
demoralized by this we had put ourselves
out there we had an idea that we
believed in and we really wanted people
to be as excited about it as we were but
we didn't get that
but it's okay because we were young and
stupid so we decided to do it anyways
so toward the end of 2012 when we were
getting ready to launch this company we
created a landing page using launch rock
and basically just tried to collect as
many email addresses as we could of
people that might be interested in this
service
we shared it on our personal facebook
pages asked some friends and families to
share it as well and ended up collecting
about 100 email addresses at the end of
the month
so when we were ready to launch at the
beginning of 2013 we sent an email out
to all those hundred people asking them
to sign up of the hundred we got 12
converted into paying subscribers
so this may not sound like a lot but we
had 12 people paying us real money that
was like we were totally blown away by
that fact we couldn't believe that
people would trust us to send them music
let alone with their credit card
information
so this was something that was really
cool for us it really made us realize
that maybe there is you know maybe this
kernel of an idea there's something here
that there are potentially people that
would be interested in paying for
something like this
so as we kept going we started to grow
pretty slowly we got from 12 to 25 to 40
to 50 eventually by the end of the
summer we got to about a hundred and we
it was just my co-founder and i we had
bootstrapped the whole thing we hadn't
spent a dollar on marketing we relied
solely on word of mouth
and so fast forward to the end of the
year we have 250 subscribers we have a
team of four people and it's still a
pretty cute side business you know it's
nothing to write home about we're not
making any money from it it's nothing
that we can sustain one person let alone
four people on
so we kind of had to have a gut check
you know we had to we had to think about
is this something that we really want to
do or is it just going to be a side
project forever
and what we ultimately decided is that
we were going to pour everything that we
had into this company we decided that we
were going to overall overhaul our
packaging redesign our website refine
our messaging we were going to put
ourselves out there even further doing
cold calls and emails and trying to get
as much media coverage as we could and
eventually some smaller things started
to hit and we started to grow a little
bit quicker and then some large scale
things started to hit and we started to
grow exponentially to now we're we're
over 2 000 customers in 35 countries
worldwide and it's sustaining four
people full time
so as i look back at this it's hard it's
hard not to think about where we came
from and
you know in thinking about this we
we learned a lot and we have grown a lot
we've done a lot and we still have a lot
of things to do and a lot of stuff to
learn but we've built something that
people really care about and that's what
matters to us
and so what i've learned through this
process is that
as you're building a business you're
always going to have critics and you're
always going to have self-doubt and you
have a choice as an entrepreneur you can
either show up and try and build
something and deliver or you can go home
and cave into the pressure
and as an entrepreneur you have to have
some sort of reckless abandon where
you're going to force yourself to pursue
through the discomfort and build
something that you believe in and that's
what makes you a true entrepreneur
so if i were to leave you with anything
it's don't wait for the right time or
the right idea the right validation on
your product just go and build something
today because you never know where it's
going to take you it could bring you to
a stage like this in san francisco in a
place where you've never been before
with 400 brand new friends so thank you
guys
you